uh hi hi hello it's me um it's tom um look
i'm i'm sorry to interrupt um i just i
um i've noticed that in these long superhero
montages loki tends to get you know a bit left
out even though arguably he's incredibly
heroic himself you know cunning charming
i could go on but but but maybe why don't i
just prove it to you wednesdays are the new fridays
and now a special look at marvel studios
original series loki maybe loki wants to
mix it up is that possible you can change hi this
variant is insubordinate stubborn unpredictable
he's doing great you need the god of
mischief but he's really arrogant i am loki
and i am burdened with glorious purpose
unbelievable wherever you go it's just
death destruction the literal ends of worlds
original series streaming
june 9th only on disney plus
Welcome back everyone big surprise another new
loki trailer just after releasing another loki
trailer so we'll break it all down obviously i'll
explain what's going on with the big marvel phase
4 schedule change because it is a big deal and it
means a lot for the future marvel phase 4 disney
plus series and what's going on with the movies i
love the idea that loki is hijacking a different
avengers trailer to make his announcement too
is a very classic loki move stealing something
from someone so that he can get more attention
for himself if you're brand new to the channel
of course i'll be doing videos for all the loki
episodes be sure to subscribe to get all of those
they'll be coming now on june 9th big schedule
change but obviously this trailer they just have
tom hiddleston complaining about how loki wasn't
featured in any of the big marvel phase 4 trailer
videos like they released that giant marvel
phase 4 movies trailer there's no looking in
there and even during the infinity saga of movies
marvel phase one phase two phase three most of the
time in the big avengers trailers loki did not
get featured a lot compared to the other core
avengers characters like avengers infinity war
trailer the avengers end game trailer he wasn't
really in those that much even though he was big
parts of those movies a critical part of the plot
like he complains loki tends to get pushed
to the back a bit left out thus a lot of his
misbehaving and mischief so that's why they play
this announcement trailer as if he's hijacking
some different avengers trailer like they play a
totally different soundtrack that sounds like a
generic avengers soundtrack with captain america
shield thor's hammer iron man's helmet before he
interrupts and is like excuse me just one moment
all the big a-list avengers is a great metaphor
for his character arc a lot of his mischief in
the trouble that he causes around the nine realms
is really just desperate cries for attention
from his father odin wanting to be recognized
as worthy the same way he feels like thor gets
recognizes worthy metaphorically and literally
because he's wielding mjolnir after odin puts his
enchantment on it at least until it gets destroyed
by hella i know we're getting the new version of
the hammer during thor 4 love and thunder i'll
explain that during some separate video there'll
be more thor force stuff happening pretty soon
but they made this huge change to the marvel phase
4 schedule and the way they're releasing all the
disney plus stuff so this isn't just for the loki
series like this is important of things to come
it's a really good change normally you hear
about changes of the schedule and you think it's
a delay it's not anything like that they're not
moving it because of a bad reason so don't worry
they really released this to say that loki is
going to be releasing episodes on wednesday
every week instead of friday so this isn't
like a one-off thing which is a huge change
for marvel and disney plus just in general
because normally every single major marvel
disney plus series like the mandalorian or
the clone wars season 7 episodes last year
all the marvel wand division episodes earlier
this year falcon and winter soldier episodes
always released their new episodes on fridays the
only exception to that was during the mandalorian
season one they released two episodes in the first
week and then they skipped the week that rise of
skywalker movie came out in theaters but 99 of the
time it's always been friday now what's happening
is they're expanding their release slate because
they have about 10 new star wars live action
series and a couple animated ones in about 12 new
marvel series that they announced for disney plus
is that eventually you'll have the really big
marvel stuff in the really big star wars series
overlapping with their new episodes really good
example of that is that next year they'll have the
mandalorian season 3 obi-wan kenobi episodes and
maybe even the ahsoka episodes and there's going
to be bare minimum four to five new marvel series
some of those will be six episodes per series and
some of them will be like nine to ten episodes
per series currently next year this is what
marvel has on their schedule and this is in order
of release date assuming that nothing is delayed
or shuffled again so it's she-hulk then moon night
secret invasion episodes maybe what if season two
because there will be a season 2 of that show the
iron heart series and then guardians of the galaxy
holiday special at the end of the year so for
example if they're releasing the new mandalorian
season 3 episodes every friday they don't want
to cannibalize the attention for those episodes
if some of the series overlaps with the moon
night episodes or the secret invasion episodes
so they're just putting some of the series on
other days of the week there are six other days
in the week that exist the only reason why they
started releasing episodes on friday is kind of
because netflix did that and because nobody
was going to movie theaters on the weekends
it everyone was just generally staying in their
homes because they had to because of the virus
also overlapping episodes is happening right now
between marvel and star wars they're actually
releasing star wars bad batch episodes on fridays
every week there are about 16 episodes of that in
season 1. it's kind of like their clone wars
season 7 sequel series it literally overlaps
with the clone wars ending and features some of
the same animation style the same team from dave
filoni same actors a lot of the same characters
so it kind of feels like clone wars season 8
and because movies are coming back to theaters
and weekends tend to be when most people go
out and see movies or used to before the virus
things are slowly getting better around the world
it just makes sense that they would use another
day of the week to post their really major content
and really they don't need a special day during
the week to release episodes any day that marvel
posts a new major episode for one of their bigger
series it automatically becomes a special day like
they could release new marvel and star wars
episodes at 4 00 a.m on a thursday and that
would not affect viewership at all so eventually
you're going to see more of this happening when dc
also starts releasing its new hbo series based on
all their upcoming movies like for instance james
gunn's suicide squad spin-off series about john
cena's character peacemaker all those episodes are
supposed to start releasing around january next
year in 2022 around the same time when marvel is
going to be releasing its she-hulk episodes at
least assuming there are no delays they haven't
announced any big delays or anything like that so
marvel and dc are not going to release their brand
new flagship episodes of major series on the same
day one of them will wind up moving their series
to another day is the exact same phenomenon with
new movies like dc and marvel try to not release
their movies on the same day there are some easter
eggs in them putting loki on wednesdays though
that some of you may have realized if you're
big fans of norse mythology they could have put
loki on any day of the week they wanted to like
sunday tuesday even saturday but i think one of
the reasons why they put it on wednesday at least
one of the smaller reasons was because wednesday
the day takes its name from the germanic woden's
day which is their word for odin's day the days of
the week are all named for norse gods in mythology
with the exception of saturday that's why in neil
gaiman's american gods mr wednesday is a pseudonym
for this version of odin the other days of the
week go like this so sunday is named for seoul
goddess of the sun it's literally the sun's day
monday is named for manny the goddess of the
moon manny's day tuesday is named for tyr god
of war tears day wednesday is named for odin
woden woden's day like i said thursday as you
probably guessed is named for thor thor's day and
friday is named for frigga frigga's day the reason
why saturday isn't part of that norse mythology is
because it's named for saturn the roman god saturn
was not a norse god so they're probably just
having some fun making a reference big callback
to loki pretending to be odin for so long in the
marvel movies between the events of thor the dark
world and thor ragnarok loki took odin's identity
and his throne and now he's literally taking his
day of the week so it's varying the tone of him
jokingly taking over this fake avengers trailer
that they used for him to make his announcement
classic loki move just stealing other people's
stuff to get people to pay attention to him but
just because they're putting loki on wednesdays
doesn't mean that all the other series when they
do start doubling up with multiple series per week
will be on wednesdays and fridays they could wind
up picking some other day i think a lot of it
just depends on what else is happening during that
part of the year the next big marvel series after
the loki episodes will be what if there'll be 10
episodes in season 1 for that so way more episodes
than even one division then they actually just
released a new version of the trailer video that
i just posted yesterday so i'll link that at the
end of this just because a lot of the footage is
similar but it's basically mobius owen wilson's
character trying to advocate for loki or this
version of loki this variant to ravana renslayer
or judge renslayer that's gugu mbatha-raw
she wants to delete him from the timeline because
she thinks he'll be more troubled than he's worth
she might be right but the thing about the
time variance authority is that they monitor
all timelines like they see the branch timelines
that loki created when he stole the tesseract and
they're moving in to try and fix that the time
keepers that created the time variance authority
exist at the end of all time in space at the end
of the universe so they've seen everything that's
ever going to happen in the main timeline so
people like mobius have already seen all of loki's
timeline in the mcu so he knows that original loki
redeemed himself eventually in avengers infinity
war so he believes that this alternate version
of loki who's now a variant could also do the
same thing given enough time they've been a lot of
you that have asked if they're going to be selling
those t-shirts with variant on them is merch maybe
they'll do that that would actually be pretty cool
but if it wasn't clear when loki stole the
tesseract he became an alternate universe
version of loki marvel is using the ancient one's
speech to the hulk about alternate timelines is
their sort of guidelines for rules about alternate
realities when someone steals an infinity stone
from this reality and takes it somewhere else
in the timeline they create a branch timeline
that becomes a fully alternate reality so on the
screen here from the time variance authority all
these branches are a bunch of alternate realities
where things just go completely off the rails
like you see different scenes where the world
seems like it burns to the ground you have the
rubble of the avengers tower in new york in the
background and one of them the other really cool
thing about owen wilson's character is that he's
also a big fantastic four character mobius is
mostly from the fantastic four comics his name
is literally mobius m mobius and they call him
moby for short he's just meant to be like a senior
level executive within their organization when
they introduced him in the comics he was actually
in the middle of trying to prosecute the fantastic
four for illegal time use continuity theft and
other various charges they eventually wound up
letting mr fantastic and the rest of them go under
his supervision under sort of like time travel
probation we have a big fantastic four movie
that's coming up in the mcu i don't know how much
this is going to set that up there are various
connections through the time variance authority
because they appeared in the fantastic four comics
so much also kind of through king the conqueror
who's connected to the ravonna renslayer character
that i talked about in my other trailer video
but i think a lot of that's just world building
and easter eggs and connections the way that
there were a lot of easter eggs connecting the
marvel phase one phase two and phase three movies
now that we're in marvel phase four they're just
sort of expanding using the multiverse in the time
travel tropes all the marvel phase four disney
plus series are meant to set up and cross over
with future movies so obviously we're talking
about alternate timelines alternate realities
multiverse stuff this will also probably help
set up doctor strange too multiverse of madness
everyone let me know in the comments what do
you think about marvel and star wars sort of
alternating days during the week with their
new episodes i feel like it'll be good for
everyone too much on the same day just big
overload everyone click here for my brand new
marvel eternals trailer breakdown that marvel
phase 4 trailer and click here for that other
brand new loki trailer footage and learn
about the connections to king the conqueror
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!